a shot with black dry and I threw a
makeup artist and then I got Angela
Simmons and Yo Gotti through a
clothing stylist good names man you
don't ask for autographs
you don't ask for a feature
I would have used hey here's my mixtape
hey you listen to the hip-hop
what
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys this is a continuation
episode uh where Joseph was telling us
about his time in the military service
specifically the US Marines uh 10 years
in the service what made you decide that
10 was seven surgeries yeah he hit it
right on what is it what oh it's 7 30
really seven surgery that's what the uh
that's the reason why you're like this
shit's beat me up yeah I actually had a
talk with my dad and uh he was like man
you gotta think about your shelf life
so uh that's kind of one of the big
factors and uh
photography kind of like had fell in my
lap during the time like right as I was
about to get out I was kind of just
getting good with photography and stuff
like that so uh when I got promoted to
staff sergeant and they moved me to
North Carolina that's where I kind of
like started my whole like photography
Venture I was traveling like
three hours just to do a free photo
shoot so I can like build my skills out
and stuff like that and then I met my
best friend Trevor he's uh the one that
took me in and was like yo if you ever
need a place to stay while you're in
Wilmington like you just stay at my
house and then so on the weekend she let
me I'd go over there on Fridays he let
me stay at his house from Friday to
Sunday and then I'd come back instead of
just driving every single day yeah
freaking three hours just to go do a
shoot so and you got uh how did you get
so good at photography was it just on
your own just trying oh yeah YouTube
University
so uh military pay for that one too long
yeah yeah they do they I feel like they
pay for everything now they just throw
money at you you know I'm trying to I'm
signing up I shut up bro I'm trying to
get on those uh you see those Instagram
ads where it says like oh if you've
Drank In The Water from Camp Lejeune and
stuff like that like
payouts or something are those like
Clash action lawsuits or something uh I
think I think they are
like I had a lady actually call me she
was like hey um I hear that you're in
the military are you
um
yeah are you inquiring about you know
such and such and I was like uh yeah I
had called about it but I didn't think I
was you know eligible for anything like
that and then so they ran like my
history and they're like oh it's only
for like these this date and this date
so like yeah if you're at the base from
like this date to this day and you were
doing this they've been thinking
that's cool I don't want people to call
me to tell me that they want to give me
money I know I wish I was on that list
yeah without any of the complications
from whatever I drank
exactly I don't want that I don't want
that yeah I want money
I got seven dollars from Toyota from a
class action lawsuit it just showed up
in the mail his airbags or what I don't
know it was like a recall but I never
seven dollars I'm still waiting for Kia
oh wow
um they say you can get up to like 6200
and you best believe I'm gonna come for
that 6200. you could probably get the
full amount yeah that's a lot
yeah yeah yeah
if they if they hit you up and was like
hey you want to be a brand ambassador
would you do it for like tons of money
yeah if I can crash the car
and you have to agree to say that the
whole story was fake
the store was fabricated it didn't
happen I just misplaced my keys I
crashed every car into this wall real
quick then we have a fun deal
oh man I thought you liked money so
every single time barter counts his like
experience in the do you know what BART
is yeah we were talking about him okay
um every time he recounts his stories
about the military he always has to talk
about how many like Dixie's seen yeah he
saw a lot of dick so what kind of
stories you got dude
so what you got three SD cards you have
how many Fortress have you done yeah I
mean I feel like the grunts is probably
a lot worse like if you're a grunt you
probably see a lot of swinging dicks
what is a girl to get you mentioned that
twice now and I tried to pretend like I
knew what that was the first bro we know
what grunts are then yeah well we know
Joe's asking he's from Japan so he
doesn't know a bunch of our terminology
is basically the Infantry part of it
yeah gotcha oh you got that yeah
can we move on please
stop holding up this conversation
there's like different different
um like uh I guess like Grunts and
different sections they all have
different personalities yeah like we
have a thing going between like you have
the grunts and then they call us Pogues
Pogues Personnel other than grunts
oh [__] he's about a pretty big like
those are really heavy
that's tight what else what else is
there it's just those two fronts and
posts oh crunching Pogues
so then it's what's what's in The Pogues
crew like the
supplies.com you have you know you have
the cooks you know yeah Essentials so
so the the they're not what do you say
was Bart com because he said he had to
just keep calling this number and to
make sure it worked yeah he was a
guarding he was guarding like graveyards
or something he would just be like hello
yes the phone works
but he never said he was a Pogue yeah
all right we're gonna we're gonna
surprise him on that yeah
I don't think bar was in the military
dude I'm starting to question his
stories I've never heard him mention
Pogues at all I never heard that either
so at the how did you transition to
becoming a photographer because if
you're you're doing it um mainly as a
hobby how did you know that you wanted
that to be your thing uh because I was
just spending so much time on it like
every single like second that I had that
I was away from the military was totally
focused on photography but you weren't
doing it prior to military at all no not
at all wow are you the
leaves kind of photographer or like
product or butt cheeks kind yeah
like when they drizzle leaves
so uh I've actually done like
I try to do like every single aspect of
Photography so I've done the leaves
stuff
you know
um and especially in La when I first got
here it was just all like butt stuff but
stuff sexual stuff
lingerie
it was that stuff you know just to try
and build up yeah just everything kind
of like how all the filmmakers do either
student stuff or uh wedding stuff yeah
they all do wedding stuff oof never got
into that one yeah I don't really like
what it is I almost actually lost the
wedding ring on one of my photos I had a
little crazy you lost it probably one of
the worst photo shoots I've ever had in
my life like because no I almost lost oh
God so it say that you lost it yeah
I had a photo shoot in North Carolina
right one of my uh old Master Gunnery
sergeants very high up in the military
um he had called me out to go shoot his
wedding and I was like yeah yeah I'll do
it so it flew me from you know
California North Carolina stayed at my
friend's house
um
and I had to drive out to this place in
North Carolina on the beach to shoot the
wedding
well I didn't have a vehicle so I took
my my boy's bike to have a motorcycle
license
um so
I knew exactly where the place was put
it in on my phone put the phone on the
little holder for the motorcycle I'm
taking off got my headset on my airpods
I'm driving next thing you know my music
cuts off and I'm like wait what the
oh no I looked down on my phone
fell off on the highway
so now I'm like damn I don't even know
how to you know I don't have directions
to the location of the wedding anymore
I'm about to be late now so I Circle
back I'm trying to look for my phone I
don't find my phone
the only thing I remember is
the
the my master gardener started saying
that they're having a wedding on the
beach
it was at the wedding
yeah
there's a wedding photo shoot I thought
it was like a wedding so I didn't know I
didn't know how to get there so I just
knew the general area of where it was so
then I started driving started driving
and then uh I pulled over at this gas
station I was like hey do you know where
a Swansboro is can you direct me that
way and they're like yeah if you just
keep going straight over the bridge
you'll hit Swansboro so I started
driving over to Swansboro get into there
and I'm looking for I go towards the
beach and I'm looking for like houses on
the beach well I end up finding like
this little like Cottage type Hotel deal
I end up walking in and this lady was on
the phone and she was just like oh just
wait a second okay okay so I ended up
waiting she got off the phone she comes
over and say hello can I help you I'm
like yeah yeah I ended up losing my
phone I need to shoot a wedding I know
it's within this area is there any
weddings that are shot on the beach over
here and they're like oh yeah there's a
there's actually a wedding uh venue
place over here she's like yeah there's
like five of them
so I ended up heading to that venue spot
and it just so happened to be the exact
place I was going to shoot so I was like
yes freaking now I'm about to have a
great day got here on time you know I
don't give a [__] about my phone right
now oh wow so then uh I take the Rings
and you know I'm gonna go around and go
shoot on the beach with the Rings
so then I take them out to the beach in
the sand then I put them on the like the
table shooting up I put it on this
little wooden log I'm starting to shoot
them and then
starting to walk back to uh without the
ring I'm starting to walk back to go
give them the Rings
and uh I bumped the table and the
bride's wedding ring falls in the sand
and I could not find it whatsoever could
not find yourself I'm sitting here like
trying to fish through the thing
and now the wedding rings yes that's how
I lost my
like magnetic Beach finders quickly
please help oh my God so now so I'm
sitting here like digging digging
digging trying to find this uh this ring
right and I'm like [__] bricks right
now but it's my old Master gonna start I
know how crazy he is too so like I don't
want to piss him off and then so uh I
don't even tell them that I lost the
Rings I go up to uh the owner of the the
beach house that we were at and I was
like ma'am I it does this happen at all
I was like I just lost the legend he's
in the sand and she's like okay don't
panic this does happen as long as you
know the general area like will be fine
and I was like all right so we ended up
going out there and she's like okay
where did you exactly drop it at and I
was like I dropped it within like this
little area it has to be over here and
she's like okay calm down she's like
when you go into the sand make sure you
you come at an angle and just rise up
like slowly he's probably like going
like this and it's bearing her further
mistake
been there done that yeah yeah so we
just kept doing that kept doing that and
then she's the one that pulled it out of
the sand
five
I would have walked into
please never come out
holy [__] yeah and then you know we
never talked about it they don't even
know about it nothing like that and this
allegedly happened we don't know if this
is not a real story this is a this is a
fun fake story hey that'd be excited if
you found a better rig
he's like damn
damn
but
just imagine though like I'm sitting
here shooting your wedding
and I lose the bride's wedding rings
like oh man so they didn't know that you
almost could have missed the whole thing
and you almost could have ruined the
whole thing yeah
[Laughter]
was that the first wedding you shot that
was the first wedding I shot without my
younger brother because my younger
brother he does video too and uh I
normally would just only shoot with him
and that was the first time I did it by
myself and that was the last time is
your younger brother the one that always
makes sure that things don't get lost
yeah he's actually pretty good at that
that's a skill set yeah afterwards did
you go back to the highway and try to
find your phone
so my phone I drove the motorcycle back
to uh my friend's house and uh he was
like sleeping and then I took his phone
and then used to find my iPhone and
found it in the middle of the road
yeah so it's not a really lucky day bro
yeah yeah nothing but Matt that's
awesome that's awesome bro holy [__]
holy [__] man that's my wedding story
unlucky lucky guy yeah that's such it
honestly that's the best call to be like
find a person who maybe has done this
before at a wedding where the ring is
lost and then ask them what to do like
that such
you know it's she owns the beach house
she hosts weddings there so yeah
right right you know like nobody's gonna
handle that better than her yeah you
asking for directions for the beach is
another [__] thing that most people
wouldn't do exactly oh the lady actually
printed me out like directions from
MapQuest dude oh I was gonna say
MapQuest is a joke but yeah it turned
out to be my glasses
she typed in Ask Jeeves first
you're like
damn dude that's nice man and then when
did you get into doing like the
photography that you do like now like
professional like all these like because
I looked up his it's actually really
[__] good yeah so is he like the
landscape with the waterfall kind or the
bikini car
I mean he's the full car polio kind oh
that's cool like high fashion yeah like
it's not a they saying a guy that's
doing a hobby
it's good good that's actually good who
are some uh like clients that you're
proud of having shot
um
uh Dua Lipa was pretty cool
um shot Little Kim
uh um
Yo Gotti Angela Simmons they've been
like really good really good clients and
very consistent with them
um I've shot with a Blac Chyna Jeffree
Star was very dope every time he says
this we should get the actual photos
that he did it'll pop up yeah that'd be
cool it's just photos from other
photographers
It's gotta be his photos that he did
every time he says this is just another
wedding ring
no so um let's tie that yeah I got into
that by uh like once I found out I was
gonna be
um moving out here I just hit up every
single model that I can find it was like
hey can we shoot can we shoot can we
shoot can we shoot that's how you do it
she was one of my La stops that I ended
up uh doing uh first person I met out
here in LA and then I saw his work
before it was where it's at now that was
said you
did you ever post the photos that he
took of you yeah oh yeah was it the butt
stuff it was the butt stuff yeah the
butt stuff
every JK fan is like where's the butt
stuff
Colleen will send you a link yeah but
there's gonna be a paper well don't
worry we'll put photos up here guess
what it's gonna be my buttons
you keep swiping you're like oh I'm
almost there and it's Nick and you're
like ah
some people will like that better true
no it's not a joke on me dude it's not a
joke on me
that's tight though those are some
really good uh clients man that's dope
yeah I feel like uh so yeah after like
getting in touch with all models I
figured out like models weren't the way
to go
um really why is that
the models that kind of want to like
kind of hold you for themselves
sometimes or you don't get because your
photos are so good that they love you
yeah
they also don't want you to work with
other people they're competing with
right is it because of the the your
style they want that to match theirs and
then they don't want other people to
have your style and
models are gonna get hired off of good
photos too it's a representation of
their work as well right so if they find
a good photographer they're going to
want to keep them but I feel like the
the hidden gems are the live within the
America the makeup artist the
hairstylist and The Stylist all my
biggest jobs have come from well because
they'll recommend yeah I got Jeffree
Star through a hair stylist I got uh a
shot with black Gina through a makeup
artist and then I got Angela Simmons and
Yo Gotti through uh
clothing stylist that's cool people
looking out man there's some big [__]
names man that means you must be really
good to work with yeah seriously yeah
definitely like to give like you know
try to stay as professional as possible
you don't ask for autographs yeah yeah
you don't ask for a future yo got
it I'm doing this on the side but hey
you listen to hip-hop
he's like what
[Laughter]
you might respect that
angle holy [__] in the middle of
shooting hey you look like someone else
likes rap or you're like hey this photo
will be better with some headphones
[Laughter]
dude I'll just put something on for
Ambiance oh [__] this song's pretty good
don't you think
you can't use it the Marines
holy [__] it's kind of a cool flow don't
story whoever this is
I'm just gonna put on the music for some
moods you know we're good at expanding
business of something you want to try
out just try it out yeah to see what the
feedback suggestions here at JK news and
that's your so like in photography
you've done so much already with
something that you haven't done yet in
photography that is like one of your
goals
[Music]
um
probably just owning my own Studio
I feel like
um like right now uh one of my friends
um
he owns uh 50 503
Studios it's uh uh he owns like multiple
Studios that like in downtown downtown
L.A Orange County and stuff like that
um so he lets me shoot in like those
locations when I just want to create so
very thankful to have him
um and then my clients wherever they get
Studios and stuff like that but that's
probably the only thing it's just
probably just owning a studio for myself
the way I want and stuff like that oh
yeah
um and then uh probably just pick up
more sponsorships nice what's your dream
uh company that you want to grab as a
sponsor Sony yeah
you're so free you can't wear gears uh I
got Westcott uh oh nice uh I was able to
get sponsored by them uh all your lights
are covered then that's cool yeah nice
much I covered a very good customer
service
um I got them through shooting the uh
George Floyd uh protest oh yeah I saw
that on your page yeah I went out there
shot a whole bunch of like black and
white photos and uh they really enjoyed
that and that kind of like slowly to
fight everything from nice how about an
aperture one amateur the sponsor
um I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't mind I
do love what Scott when it comes to
lighting though all right Avatar leans a
little more video oh how about Ross
yeah what about right Dress for Less
[Laughter]
what's your stance on their spots
love your guys's socks what if that's a
conflict with Sony somehow
they're like hey you can work with Canon
but not Ross so are you [__] gonna be
Ross if you guys want to check out
Joseph's photography the link is going
to be in the info below so yeah please
go support it's it's really amazing
photography and also if you want to get
to know more as a person DM him and then
a hit on him and stuff hit on him okay
are you single are you single by the way
uh right now yes I am ladies blow it up
yeah below
go check out the leaves waterfalls cars
butts
foreign